it was an amazing film that we shot in
2018
um it was um i think they
started doing like interviews
looking for talent like two years before
i came in
a year into the project before i started
taping
and i was the last talent to be cast in
the film we shot it in like literally a
month
in new york city um it was amazing
i got rehearsed every friday and
wednesday here if you want to see me
just like below
i have this angerous thing
it gets me in trouble
[Applause]
there's been so many different
depictions of what love is and what love
has been and
this is honestly a new form of a love
story
um obviously the only component about it
is the idea that i am transgender
and the character is transgender so
there's this new idea that's wrapped
around
love i think it's just it humanizes so
many people
and especially for me it allows people
to like have
a new introduction towards people in
society that
they often don't see but we're still
there in the shadows and now we're front
and center and
this film definitely testifies to the
ideas that the world is changing we are
involving
and people that have been missing from
society for so many years
um centuries it seems are now front and
center if you have a thing for the girls
that's fine
just do your thing with someone else
what is he doing here
that's my friend so those
aren't your real brothers not in the
like
most traditional way we look into these
two characters and they see how
unique and special they are and how the
same they are
so i think that's what this story about
and a lot of stories that are based
around transnatives in state society is
basically humanizing this experience
that people think it's just
in some ways extreme or non-conforming
to society
it really really just um stands it's
it just stands on its own and it's just
it's something to
to look at and to um look at in yourself
also
while you're looking at it you gotta
look around maybe i don't want people
thinking of something i'm not
tell me you didn't feel anything
honestly it's just it's the right time
for writers for creators for different
people for black and brown bodies from
all different walks of life to really
um take this moment to say like i'm here
too
my story also matters and it's time for
us to now say
i'm choosing to stand up and i'm
choosing to stand up with my people and
we're going to really
fight the system create a whole new
dialogue take words and give them new
meanings and really
tap into like this earthness that's
around us is grounded with people that
look like me where we can go out and
also do everything that everyone else is
doing and not just do it but do it
better